we have something to show you all that
matters is fighting the dead if they get
past the wall and we're squabbling
amongst ourselves we're finished
everybody big surprise they just
released a bunch of production bombs
about season 8 so they're rolling into
actual production like they'll
physically start working on episodes in
October in a couple weeks a couple of
you have even messaged me saying that
you've spotted Peter Dinklage in Belfast
that's just because the actors are
slowly making their way back to set but
they released all this fascinating
information about who the directors are
going to be they basically brought back
the greatest hits in terms of directors
and what the budget is going to be for
each of the episodes and it gives us a
pretty good idea of what they'll be able
to do in terms of stuff that they've cut
out in previous seasons aka direwolves
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I do Game of Thrones every week there's
even a DVD giveaway that's happening
that I'll explain at the end of the
video so the biggest thing first Dan and
Dave took the last episode to direct
themselves it makes sense you know they
spent so much time developing the series
before they ever shot the first pilot we
had this great opportunity when HBO
decided to pick up the series despite
all the problems with the pilot we got a
chance to go back and rewrite it you
know and ended up shooting the pilot in
the rest was history so it would make
sense that they would be all hands on
deck devoting a hundred percent of their
time both themselves to making sure that
everything ended the way they wanted it
to end but there are only two other
directors that are dividing up all the
other episodes so there's six episodes
total and they brought back their
superstar Miguel subhanak in David
Nutter who's also a superstar in his own
right so Miguel Zapata shot the gift
hardhome Battle of the bastards and
winds of winter he didn't come back
during season seven because of some
scheduling conflicts but he's basically
done the last couple of seasons worth of
the biggest episodes that they've had
they've been hyping up the idea that
each of the final episodes will be
feature-length meaning that it'll be
longer than an hour and it'll be in
terms of scope scale big battles big
action set-pieces lots of CG without
sparing any expense this is actually him
talking about his big episodes from
season 6
luckily we got Miguel Sebastian egg back
who is our maestro from heart home in
season 5 that was basically a massacre
this is a battle this is the story of a
battle
never done that before they really
wanted to kind of get into the mindset
of what it would be like to be in a
battle like that if the name David
Nutter isn't familiar to you he started
directing episodes back during season
two and he's sort of a superstar in his
own right he's actually directed all the
pilots for all the DC TV shows he did a
lot of the classic x-files his resume is
super long he's been around a little bit
longer than Miguel subhanak but you kind
of get the idea from this is that
they're bringing back their biggest
feature quality directors like if
they're going to make each of these
episodes feel like a movie in its own
right within the season then you want a
director that can handle that scope and
scale like a lot of people feel like
there were a couple episodes during
season 7 that really delivered on big
action set-pieces the visuals were
amazing but some of the characters got
lost in the shuffle especially with the
way they weave the story just jumping
forward in time every chance they got so
the important thing when you do stuff
like that is not to lose the characters
in all these people that they got to do
the final episodes are really good at
that so I'm actually really optimistic
that the final episodes will be as good
as you would want them to be but even
though I think that's the more important
news that they drop today the even
bigger idea is that the budget for each
of the final six episodes is 15 million
dollars the going rate for like the
really really expensive TV shows that
you hear about Netflix producing is a
closer to 10 million dollars way back in
the early seasons they only had closer
to 6 million dollars then they got that
bumped up to 8 then you got to season 6
and they wanted to do big episodes like
Battle of the bastards like I included
that behind the scenes clip that took a
little bit more so they slowly got the
budget bumped up above 10 million
dollars and then obviously because
things got so crazy with the Dragons
this past season and they want to take
that even further without having to cut
other stuff out like they cut the
direwolves out because of budgetary
reasons they upped that to 15 million
dollars so that is freaking crazy even
though there are probably television
shows that have spent more money in
total when you consider all the episodes
this final season of Game of Thrones
will technically be the most expensive
season of all time you know like I said
that just translates to more episodes on
the scale of hardhome and battle of the
bastards where you have a lot of extras
a lot
animals like you have a lot of horses
like they say they always had to pick
between doing a giant in doing the
direwolves that was the big reason
during battle of the bastards is because
they wanted to do the giant and they had
to pick one or the other and then
probably the most expensive thing that
I'm expecting them to try is aerial
dragon battles so even doing a couple
dragons for a couple minutes on screen
is super expensive for them like during
episode six but imagine you have Jon
Snow and Daenerys both riding Ragle and
drogue on fighting the night King on
Viserion so you have three dragons going
at each other at the same time in order
to make that look amazing you're gonna
have to spend a dumptruck of money and
we're not talking about like two seconds
and then the fights over we're talking a
pro long gated aerial dragon battle so
amazing that it will burn your eyes out
of their sockets you may not realize it
- because the budget was so much smaller
even though six million dollars is a
[ __ ] ton of money to spend on an episode
of television during the Blackwater
episode they said that they almost had
to skip that battle altogether no
wildfire nothing because they almost
didn't have the money to do it but HBO
PO need up a little bit extra for them
the other funny example is when Tyrians
in full armor at the Battle of Green
folk and bronze like stay low and he
gets knocked out is he's rushing into
battle and they use it from his
perspective as a way to skip the battle
entirely and save the money that it
would have taken to actually shoot that
so I feel like really the biggest thing
here obviously you know sort of teas
like the big action set-pieces having
big crowd shots like this with a lot of
actual actors the aerial dragon battles
but I think people will be most happy to
see them use this extra money to bring
the direwolves back the ones that are
still alive that obviously means that
when they go back to Winterfell we get
to have scenes with ghost ghost gets to
meet Daenerys and even funnier the
dragons that'll be an interesting scene
ghost versus drogon we'll just see how
that works out and then like we should
have seen these last couple of seasons
he can take ghost into battle like he
should have been at the Battle of the
bastards helping Jon Snow fight the
other bonus is that they could do the
super pack that George R Martin has been
teasing from the book so Nymeria could
come back with a giant horde of regular
wolves she's the only dire wolf in that
pack though it's her running around the
Riverlands like we saw when REM
with her during season seven with a
whole bunch of wolves we only saw a
small snapshot of it here if you're a
big fan of the actors in real life -
it's not necessarily Game of Thrones
news but Kit Harington supposedly got
engaged to Rose Leslie so he's actually
marrying Ygritte in real life so very
happy for him hopefully it all works out
[Music]
but here's my big question for you guys
now that we know that they have 15
million dollars per episode where do you
want them to have big battles obviously
there has to be one at Winterfell
because that's where the army of the
Dead is marching but that just makes me
feel like they do have the money to take
the army of the Dead the night king with
vissarion down to King's Landing even
though I think most of the bigger
battles will take place up in the north
so what will happen is I'll do a new Q&A
video in a couple days so just leave all
your questions you want me to include
for that in the comments congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Leon
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is just be a
subscriber or leave a comment on the
video I'll announce a new winner when I
post that new game of Thrones video but
you can click here to learn all about
the Valyrian swords on the TV show in
season 8 and you can click here for
brand new Rick and Morty thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight